l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi adopté
par l'assemblée nationale relatif à la
bioéthique dans la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur adrien taquet
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'enfance
et des familles
je suis le président j'ai le président
de la commission monsieur les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices les sénateurs le projet de
loi de bioéthique est un texte à part
qui dois je le rappeler fixe des limites
aux possibilités offertes par les
progrès de la recherche
concilier le possible et le souhaitable
voilà la mission délicate qui est la
nôtre qui est la vôtre dans les débats
qui nous réunissent depuis bientôt deux
ans sur ce texte
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
pour toutes les femmes était un
engagement du président de la république
un engagement qui trouve dans ce projet
de loi des conditions d'application
sereine digne et sécurisé pour les
enfants issus de ce dispositif c'est
tout le sens du travail colossal qui a
été menée sur le droit d'accès aux
origines et sur l'instauration d'un
nouveau mode de situation le texte
vous le savez permet également d'autres
avancées je pense en particulier aux
dons d'organes croisé à l'accès aux
transmission des informations génétiques
je pense également à l'encadrement des
traitements d'intelligence artificielle
je pense enfin la gouvernance bioéthique
se trouve renforcée qui consolide en
cela le débat démocratique
je sais que certains sur ses bancs et
aimerait parfois aller plus loin sur
certains sujets
d'autres peut-être moins loin et je
respecte ses souhaits qui expose des
aspirations sociétal sincère et parfois
légitimes
ce texte ne satisfera pas tout le monde
il sera jugé tantôt frileux tantôt
audacieux mais il sera j'en suis
convaincu un texte équilibré
autrement dit un texte ambitieux sans
être aventurier un texte responsable
sans être tiède
le projet de loi accorde de nouveaux
droits ils apportent les ajustements
rendus nécessaires par les évolutions
techniques et sociétal accorder de
nouveaux droits et de nouvelles
protections
c'est la marque d'un progressisme qui a
gardé le sens des conquêtes et croyez
bien que je ne perde
des principes qui donnent toute leur
force à ces droits nouveaux à chaque
ligne de chaque article nous avons
scrupuleusement veillé à préserver
l'équilibré entre le respect de la
dignité de la personne humaine
l'autonomie de chacun et la solidarité
de tous ces mesures recouvrent notamment
avec l'article premier du projet de loi
l'ouverture de l'accès à l'assistance
médicale à la procréation aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes seules et non
mariés nous avons pour cela respecter un
impératif catégorique offrir un cadre
protecteur pour l'enfant à naître qui a
sa majorité aura la possibilité sans
condition d'accéder aux informations
relatives aux tiers donneur ainsi qu'à
l'identité de ce dernier
ce cadre protecteur sera garantie par
une gestion centralisée des données
relatives au donneur aux dons et aux
enfants nés de dons par l' agence de la
biomédecine commission d'accès aux
origines accueillera les demandes des
personnes nées de dont elle sollicitera
l' agence pour obtenir les informations
lui permettant d'exercer ses missions
cet article nous pouvons être fiers et
je le dis non sans émotion ce que je
pense à tous ces couples de femmes qui
depuis tant d'années s'engagent dans des
parcours du combattant pour mener à bien
leur projet parental
je veux dire à tous ces couples de
femmes que dorénavant leur projet
parental leur projet familial sera
pleinement reconnue et qu'elles seront
accompagnés comme il se doit dans leurs
démarches m'est arrivé d'entendre de
drôles de propos parfois sur de
prétendues je cite des ordres médicaux
engendrés par les techniques de
procréation médicalement assistée chez
des enfants par cet article c'est au
contraire la famille française ça
grandit dans la diversité de ses modèles
et dans la richesse de ces
configurations
c'est un enjeu d'égalité la force de
l'égalité républicaine c'est précisément
de reconnaître la diversité des
situations
la diversité des parcours la diversité
des projets de chacun dans le
quinquennat précédent le match pour tous
à participer de ce mouvement vers
l'égalité bien loin
du choc anthropologique redouté par
certains et je rends hommage à tous ceux
qui à l'époque sur ses bancs et ailleurs
ont permis à la france d'être fidèle à
sa promesse d'égalité et d'émancipation
même les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
je ne vois aucune raison valable à ce
que les équilibres qui ont pu être
trouvées à l'assemblée nationale se
heurte à des impasses du côté du sénat
j'aurais souhaité je souhaite encore
peut-être que l'assemblée se saisissent
l'opportunité de continuer à discuter à
nouveau de ce texte que comprendre les
intentions étaient peut-être tout autre
ce que je regrette si cela devait se
confirmer
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre je passe maintenant la parole à
madame corinne imbert rapporteur de la
commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ce président de la commission
spéciale mes chers collègues le 21
janvier 2020 nous engagions dans cet
hémicycle l'examen en première lecture
du projet de loi relatif à la bioéthique
près de 18 mois plus tard pour le
troisième rendez vous sur ce texte
nous ressentons une certaine déception
la navette parlementaire a pu certes se
déployer sans procédure accélérée
mais elle n'a pas permis d'enclencher un
dialogue constructif entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat
à tout le moins sur les pans les plus
visibles ou les plus importants de ce
texte
il nous appartient aujourd'hui d'en
tirer les conséquences
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission vous proposera de mettre un
terme à nos débats en votant la question
préalable
cette décision ne va jamais de soi et
plus encore quand il s'agit d'une loi de
bioéthique
nous le savons ce n'est pas une loi
toute assez comme les autres les lois de
bioéthique ont vocation à traduire un
équilibre entre ce que permet la science
est ce que la société est prête à
autoriser les enjeux sont aujourd'hui
majeur en matière de recherche dans
l'avancée rapide des connaissances ouvre
d'opportunités de mieux comprendre la
complexité du vivant
ce texte est attendu par la communauté
scientifique sur ce volet essentiel il
serait sorti plus fort du parlement en
s'appuyant sur un consensus à notre
regret cela ne sera pas le cas au sénat
nous avons eu à coeur d'accueillir les
perspectives ouvertes par la recherche
notamment celles sur les cellules
souches induites pluripotentes sans
céder sur nos principes éthiques
fondamentaux
ce texte trace en ce sens des avancées
dont nous avons soutenu le principe nous
aurions parfois souhaité aller plus loin
pour ne pas prendre un retard
préjudiciable à la recherche française
dans un environnement international
hautement concurrentiel nous avons
également tenu à infirmer des limites
claires en matière de recherche
notre préoccupation principale a été de
veiller à ce qu'elle ne franchissent pas
les lignes rouges que sont notamment le
respect de la barrière des espèces sur
les embryons chimérique les questions
soulevées par ce type de manipulation ne
peuvent être balayées d'un revers de la
main est laissée à la seule appréciation
de l' agence de la biomédecine
sur ce sujet comme sur beaucoup d'autres
nous n'avons pas été suffisamment
entendus par nos collègues députés comme
par les ministres
qui se sont succédé au banc certes au
terme de nos travaux nous retenons quand
même quelques facteurs de satisfaction
des propositions issues du sénat
permettront demain avec l'extension
ciblée du dépistage néonatal de prendre
en charge des nouveaux nés sans perdre
de précieuses semaines ou années de
traitement pour autant le dialogue s'est
figé sur les divergences profondes entre
nos deux assemblées comme celle portant
sur le chapitre relative à l'assistance
médicale à la procréation même sur des
points précis comme l'établissement de
la filiation ou les modalités de l'accès
à l'identité des donneurs de gamètes
les portes sont trop souvent restées
fermées aux propositions de notre
rapporteur muriel jourda et cela dès la
fin de la première lecture sur un sujet
apparemment moins clivant comme celui de
la gouvernance en matière de bioéthique
l'assemblée nationale a préféré de même
ne pas tenir compte de nos observations
c'est donc avec regret vous l'aurez
compris mais en responsabilité que la
commission spéciale vous demandera de
voté la question préalable à l'issue de
la discussion générale
si nous n'avons pu parvenir à un
consensus sur ce texte nos travaux
auront contribué à enrichir certains de
ses volets et surtout nous avons montré
dans nos échanges lors de ses nombreuses
heures à débattre d'enjeux touchant
parfois intimes notre capacité à nous
écouter les uns aux autres et à faire
cheminer nous réflexion collective
au delà de nos divergences ce qu'ils
font au final l'honneur de notre dégoût
démocratie parlementaire en particulier
ici au sénat je vous remercie bien merci
chers collègues la parole est à bernard
jomier rapporteur de la commission
spéciale
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ne se présente la commission
mes chers collègues nous arrivons juste
dix ans après la présidente lois de
bioéthique au terme d'un processus
législatif particulièrement longue
certes ralenti par la crise sanitaire
ce projet de loi présenté par le
gouvernement à l'été 2010 9 comme ça a
été rappelé et nourri des états généraux
de la bioéthique qui ont animé le débat
public en 2018
l'exercice de remise à plat périodique
de ces lois est nécessaire du fait de la
spécificité de la bioéthique mais son
rythme gagnerait à être plus rapide pour
tenir compte de l'évolution rapide de la
science et de la société et la
définition de son contenu d'ailleurs
gagnerait à être moins liés à des
calculs politiques
le texte qui sera définitivement adopté
par le parlement n'est pas parfait il
laissera aux uns et aux autres
dans cet hémicycle pour des raisons
différentes d'ailleurs un goût
d'inachevé même s'il traces d avancer
notre commission spéciale aurait
souhaité sur certains volets aller plus
loin par exemple pour valoriser l'acte
altruiste de dons d'organes en matière
de recherche ou encore comme l'avait
défendu notre collègue rapporteur
olivier henno pour encadrer l'accès à
des tests génétiques déjà présents dans
notre quotidien sur d'autres points
les garde-fous que nous proposions n'ont
pas été retenus par le député je le
regrette en ce qui concerne le don
d'organes post mortem des majeurs
protégés ou encore le délai de
conservation des gamètes de mineurs
atteints de pathologies altérant leur
fertilité que nous avions proposé
d'allonger toutefois d apport du sénat
resteront dans ce texte
et c'est le cas d'ailleurs sur la
plupart des sujets que j'ai eue a
rapporté l'extension la procédure de don
croisé d'organes a été adopté par les
députés dans la rédaction du sénat qui
en précise les modalités
nous avons également élaborer un
dispositif qui permettra d'améliorer la
prise en charge des enfants présentant
des variations du développement
génitales l'assemblée nationale a
conservé l'ouverture du don de sang aux
majeurs protégés voter dans cet
hémicycle persistant toutefois refuser
ce don de sang au mineur de 17 ans sur
les dons de corps enfin après les
récents scandales
nous avons tenu après
toute exonération général de
responsabilité pénale ces avancées
issues de nos travaux sont importantes
pour la science pour les patients je
partage cependant les regrets que
corinne imbert vient d'exprimer au nom
de la commission spéciale de n'avoir pas
trouvé un consensus plus large avec nos
collègues députés comme avec le
gouvernement sur des dispositions plus
central de ce texte
l'ouverture de l'assistance médicale à
la procréation aux couples de femmes et
aux femmes seules à cliver nos débats
tant dans cet hémicycle dans nos
dialogues aval avec l'assemblée
nationale que l'on soit favorable comme
je le suis ou au contraire pour certains
d'entre vous opposer à cette réforme
nous avons été nombreux dès la première
lecture a regretté l'adjonction de ce
sujet à une loi de bioéthique
cela a éclipsé dans le débat public
d'autres enjeux majeurs et c'est
regrettable
cela a également réduit notre capacité à
dialoguer sereinement entre les deux
chambres et a trouvé plus d'accord sur
les sujets bioéthique
après l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire a trouvé un accord
principalement en raison des divergences
insurmontables exprimé sur ce volet à
l'issue du texte a ici de la deuxième
lecture l'assemblée nationale a adopté
en nouvelle lecture un texte très proche
de ses positions antérieures
l'exercice de la navette parlementaire
mes chers collègues sans atteindre ses
limites à ce stade de nos débats même
sur des sujets sur lequel un dialogue
était a priori possible
nous ne pouvons qu'en prendre acte la
commission spéciale propose en tirer les
conséquences en opposant à l'issue de
cette discussion générale la question
préalable
ce n'est pas l'issue que l'on pouvait
espérer pour une loi de bioéthique et le
temps viendra de repenser le sens et la
méthode de révision de ces lois
et d'affirmer de délier on va dire les
calculs politiques qui procède à la
définition de son contenu de la révision
des lois de bioéthique sûr merci merci
chers collègues dans la suite de la
discussion générale
la parole est notre collègue daniel
chassant pour le groupe les indépendants
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission mesdames et messieurs le
rapporteur chers collègues
la deuxième commission mixte paritaire a
échoué et 25 articles restent en
discussion pour la troisième lecture au
sénat du projet de loi relatif à la
bioéthique et nous avons constaté de
nombreux points de désaccord je le
regrette
à l'article 1er en première lecture le
sénat avait approuvé l'ouverture de la
pma aux couples de femmes en excluant à
ce moment les femmes seules du
dispositif l'assemblée nationale propose
m une prise en charge totale pour tous
par la solidarité nationale ne céda à
limiter le remboursement de la mp aux
couples hétérosexuels infertiles à titre
personnel je suis favorable à l'accès de
la mp aux femmes seules et aux couples
de femmes en matière de remboursement je
vais proposer une solution de compromis
avec une prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale et la complémentaire santé en
cas d'absence de critères médical
d'infertilité
le sénat a rejeté à deux reprises
l'article 2 sur l'auto conservation des
ovocytes actuellement en dehors des
personnes atteintes de maladies graves
l'auto conservation des ovocytes est
uniquement possible
en contrepartie d'un don d'ovocytes cela
ne me semble pas juste
je suis donc favorable à l'ouverture de
l'auto conservation des ovocytes
le parcours de l'assistance de la pma
long et pouvant réussite de la mp n'est
pas garanti et cette démarche peut être
entreprise en gardant l'esprit d'or le
risque d'échec
c'est pourquoi c'est favorable au
diagnostic préimplantatoire
non pas pour de l'eugénisme mais pour
limiter le nombre de pousse pousse
je rejoins la position du sénat sur la
question à l'accès aux origines des
enfants issus d'un don de gamètes
je suis favorable à la communication
systématique des données non
identifiantes mais à la préservation de
l'anonymat des donneurs s'ils le
souhaitent
le sénat avait trouvé à mon sens un bon
équilibre à ce sujet et je regrette que
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas plus
cette opposition en matière de filiation
des enfants nés de pma dans un groupe de
femmes
j'approuve la position du sénat qui
proposait un dispositif d'ascq
d'adoption facilité plutôt qu'une
reconnaissance anticipée je regrette la
suppression par l'assemblée nationale de
l'article 4 bis qui marquait une
opposition très clair à la pma en
s'opposant à la reconnaissance du père
d'intention dans la transcription en
france de l'acte de naissance d'un
enfant né de gpa à l'étranger
je suis également très réticent un aux
évolutions proposées sur les recherches
visant à créer un embryon chimérique ou
transgénique
nous ne maîtrisons pas les risques du
devenir des cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines
introduite dans un embryon animal je
comprends les enjeux de cette recherche
que cette recherche représente en
matière de greffe d'organes mais nous
appréhendons cette disposition
la commission spéciale du sénat dont je
salue le travail a fait le choix de
déposer une motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable au projet de loi
les rapporteurs nous ont fait part de
l'absence de prise en compte des
préoccupations du sénat par les députés
pourtant avec une volonté réciproque des
deux assemblées un texte commun aurait à
mon avis était possible
notre groupe respecte toutes les
sensibilités qu'il représente
aussi chacun mes collègues vote aura de
façon indépendante
en ce qui me concerne malgré que je sois
favorable à la pma je voterai la motion
de rejet déposé par la commission
je remercie le merci chers collègues je
passe la parole à notre collègue daniel
salmon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité des territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
arrivons avec la troisième lecture de ce
projet de loi relatif à la bioéthique au
bout d'un long chemin il est grand temps
de statuer définitivement sur ces
dispositions dont nous pensons qu'elles
constituent pour la plupart des avancées
utile est attendu google
globalement ce texte de l'assemblée
nationale à quelques dispositions près
nous satisfait nous nous réjouissons
bien sûr qu'il est réintroduit les
mesures phares que la majorité
sénatoriale avait purement et simplement
supprimés notamment l'article premier
l'ouverture de la mp aux femmes seules
et aux couples de femmes et sa prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie
la possibilité pour les femmes d'une
auto conservation de l'ours ovocytes
l'accès aux origines pour tous les
enfants conçus avec tiers donneur à leur
majorité
si nous souhaitions aller plus loin sur
la mp post mortem ou dans le traitement
de l'accès à la mp en assurant une
égalité de traitement au regard de
l'identité de genre
il est certain que cette rédaction
constitue déjà une avancée sociétale
majeure est attendue la mp n'est pas une
concession faite à l'époque mais bien
l'aboutissement d'un long processus qui
nous amène à reconnaître une liberté
parce qu'elle correspond à une nécessité
il a une réalité biologique mais il ya
également une vérité humaine à laquelle
nous devons répondre
la société française à évoluer vers un
modèle familial qui ne se résume plus à
une configuration unique issu d'un
modèle conjugale unique nos citoyens ils
sont près les deux tiers des françaises
et français y sont favorables
il faut maintenant l'acte et nous sommes
également satisfaits que les députés
aient répondu favorablement un certain
nombre de dispositions que nous
défendions en deuxième lecture comme la
possibilité du recours au prélèvement
d'organes chez des jeunes protégés ou
encore l'interdiction de l'usagé de
l'irm fonctionnelle à des fins
judiciaires
au lieu de au-delà de ces avancées je
formulerai aussi rapidement quelques
regrets
le maintien par l'assemblée nationale de
l'article 4 bis qui interdit la
transcription total de l'acte de
naissance ou du jugement étranger
établissements la filiation d'un enfant
né d'une gpa à l'étranger
une mesure qui est à contresens des
récentes décisions judiciaires selon
lesquelles une gpa réalisés à l'étranger
ne saurait faire à elle seul obstacle
reconnaissance d'un enfant en france
d'un lien de filiation intégral pour ce
qui est des modes de filiation nous
privilégions la présomption de parenté
pour les couples non mariés pour le ou
la conjointe lorsqu'un enfant naît d'une
amp
l'idée étant d'étendre aux couples de
femmes le régime de droit commun prévu
pour les couples hétérosexuels
c'est pour nous la solution la plus à
même de garantir l'égalité entre les
couples sur les questions de recherche
nous actons de réelles divergences de
fond avec l'assemblée le sénat restant
attachés au maintien de l'interdiction
absolue de la création d'embryons
chimérique afin d'écarter tout risque de
franchissement de la barre des espèces
une position partagée par le groupe
écologiste
enfin nous regrettons que l'assemblée
n'ait pas voulu profiter de ce véhicule
législatif pour clarifier les pratiques
qui est réaffirmé que l'interruption
médicale de grossesse pour raisons
médicales ou en cas de détresse
psychosocial doit s'appliquer
uniformément dans tous les territoires
on constate encore trop souvent
localement des divergences
d'interprétation quant à l'opportunité
de prendre en considération l'ensemble
des détresses
parmi les causes du péril grave
justifiant la réalisation d'une ing mais
au final les sénateurs et sénatrices de
groupes écologistes soutiennent
globalement cette réforme
nous sommes heureux que la mp pour
toutes ce droit nouveau soit enfin
consacré dans nos sociétés
contemporaines en mutation la
reconnaissance d'un tel droit est
salutaire sur ces enjeux notre boussole
est et restera l'humain et l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
patricia chilin j'ai pour le groupe air
des pays
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission spéciale mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues réunis une nouvelle fois pour
échanger sur ce texte charnière de nos
sociétés je tenais à débuter mon propos
en remerciant tous les donneurs mise à
l'honneur il ya deux jours lors de la
20e journée nationale de réflexion sur
le don d'organes et la greffe et de
reconnaissance aux donneurs merci à
toutes celles et ceux qui par leurs dons
ou celui de leurs proches ont sauvé des
vies et qui en sombrant à l'avenir et
d'autres encore femmes réunies
aujourd'hui pour examiner le projet de
loi bioéthique
mais cet examen sera court bien trop
court à mon âme à mon goût après une
deuxième lecture complexe sénat
aujourd'hui c'est un rejet simples qui
nous attend le texte qui sera adopté
définitivement prochainement comprend
des avancées majeures et la déception de
nos débats ne doit pas effacer la portée
de ce texte
il représente une victoire pour tant de
familles ces familles du 21e siècle
singulière est belle l'ouverture de la
mp aux femmes seules aux couples de
femmes et aux couples non stérile le
démontre nous nous félicitons des
rétablissements des articles 1er et 2e
de la de l'assemblée nationale l'article
cartes concernant la filiation des
enfants nés suite à une amp pour les
couples de femmes est essentiel pour
leur reconnaissance en tant que maire au
pluriel de l'enfant dessin à 100 dès sa
naissance avec ses articles ce sont des
milliers de français françaises qui vont
voir leur vie changer cela cela ne sera
jamais assez répété un enfant nécessite
surtout d'être bercé dans l'amour de
grandir dans le respect et de s'épanouir
dans le dans la bienveillance ce texte
permettra encore davantage de parents
de pouvoir assurer cette mission
l'assemblée nationale a également
rétabli certaines modalités qui nous
apparaissent bienvenus c'est notamment
le cas de l'année n 1 de l'article 12
visant à interdire expressément usage de
l'irm fonctionnelle à des fins
judiciaires
notre amendement de rétablissement
n'avait pas été adopté lors de la
deuxième lecture dans cet hémicycle
mais nous sommes satisfaits d'avoir vu
l'article ainsi modifié à l'assemblée
nationale enfin plusieurs avancées ont
été adoptés consomme par nos deux
assemblées preuve encore de la valeur de
nos débats et de la capacité de
compromis du parlement je pense
notamment à l'article 5 étant dans le
don croisé d'organes à +22 dompaire de
donneur receveur pour améliorer l'accès
à la greffe à l'article 13 permettant
d'encadrer les dispositifs de
neuromodulation ou encore à l'article 18
visant à encourager les passerai le soin
recherche par l'utilisation facilité des
échantillons conservés à d'autres fins
ce texte répond à l'enjeu unique des
projets de lois bioéthiques amener nos
politiques publiques vers l'avenir dans
le respect des principes éthiques et
moraux que nous qui nous sont chères
c'est à toutes ces richesses de ses
textes empreints d'une belle complexité
qu'il nous impose responsabilités et
bienveillance je tiens ici à remercier
le gouvernement de ne pas avoir fait
recours à la procédure accélérée
bien que des débats ne soient pas
toujours satisfait et bien que le
dialogue s'atténue avec le temps le
texte sera enrichi par ses multiples
examens
je tiens d'ailleurs à souligner le
travail constructif réalisé jusqu'à
présent au sein de nos deux assemblées
toutes les avancées que le texte porte
sont nécessaires elles répondent aux
attentes de nombreux citoyens aux envies
de liberté de tout et au choix de
solidarité de chacun
loin d'être accueillis ninham en est le
projet de loi bioéthique par les projets
profonde et personnels qui elle qui la
bordent appelle des visions divergentes
elles font bible et au sein même du
groupe r des pays
et la liberté totale de chacun de ses
choix a toujours été assurée lors de ces
agapes examen mais aujourd'hui nous nous
alignons tous derrière notre souhait de
débat et nous serons donc en voix
unanime derrière celle de mon collègue
xavier iacovelli contre cette motion qui
entache ce projet de loi ambition est
nécessaire merci chers collègues la
parole à bernard fialaire pour le groupe
rdse
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission mesdames messieurs les
rapporteurs je regrette que la cmp
n'était est conclusive sur un sujet
aussi essentiel que la bioéthique la
majorité de l'assemblée nationale aurait
été intransigeante nous dit on il nous
arrive aussi hélas dans cet hémicycle de
nous heurter à une majorité sénatoriale
sûre d'elle et dominatrice pour autant
jamais nous ne renonçons à débattre ni à
argumenter pour faire évoluer les
consciences car c'est bien de cela qu'il
s'agit
cette loi de bioéthique revient
régulièrement devant le parlement pour
adapter notre législation progrès de la
science et à l'évolution des mentalités
donc plus que jamais nous ne voterons
pas au groupe rdse la question préalable
parce que dans un domaine aussi sensible
que la bioéthique qui relève de la
conscience de chacun il n'est pas devin
débat nous avons foi en la richesse de
les changes et restons ouverts aux
évolutions possibles de nos avis par
l'expression d'argumentation de
convaincante lors je voudrais revenir
sur des faux procès qui se sont tenues
sur des querelles sémantiques qu'il
conviendrait de dépasser on a opposé le
droit de l'enfant avec sa noblesse et
son caractère sacré au droit à l'enfant
qui relèveraient d'exigence malvenue
comme si le droit à l'enfant n'existait
pas
lorsqu'un couple une personne souhaite
adopter l'agrément accordé n'est-il pas
d'une certaine façon un droit à l'enfant
de même pour les couples ou les mères
désireuses dame paix les équipes
médicales autorise un nombre limité de
tentatives donc de droit à l'enfant
d'une certaine mesure je trouve
également que l'on considère avec
suspicion le désir d'enfants de couples
hétérosexuels ou homosexuels comme de
parent isolé
faudrait-il avoir honte de désirer un
enfant à tout prix reconnaître que c'est
peut-être la raison d'être d'un couple
où le projet d'une vie d'une personne
sol que d'avoir un enfant pour lui
transmettre de l'affection assurer son
éducation et permettent son
épanouissement
c'est ne pas mesurer la souffrance de
parents sans enfant ni les 12
earl endurées par les femmes soumises
aux épreuves d'une amp que de considérer
ce désir comme un caprice égoïste ou
irresponsable comment pouvons nous
ajouter à cette souffrance physique une
détresse morale par le refus d'autoriser
le recours aux possibilités
thérapeutiques actuelles quel sens
aurait le progrès scientifique
si l'on en interdit le bénéfice à ceux
qui en ont besoin et le réclame le but
ultime de la médecine est de soulager
les souffrances
il faut entendre les souffrances de
celles et ceux qui réclament un recours
à la mp qu'il soit en couple
hétérosexuel homosexuel ou parfois sol
j'ai aussi entendu parler d'enfants
naissance en perd un enfant son père
cela n'existe pas il y a toujours un
père biologique qu'il soit présent ou
non connus ou inconnus mais il existe et
cela ne doit faire aucun doute dans nos
esprits comme dans l'esprit de l'enfant
d'une mère célibataire ou d'un couple
homosexuel
enfin je reviendrai sur la ligne rouge
que l'on a tracé pour la gpa la
gestation pour autrui
les enfants nés sous x qui peuvent être
adoptés sont bien le fruit d'une gpa
si les mots ont un sens certes ils ne
sont pas le fruit d'une fécondation pour
autrui qui associé à une grossesse pour
autrui
reste à ce jour interdite mais la
fécondation pour autrui est bien
autorisé pour concevoir un embryon qui
sera donnée et la grossesse pour autrui
n'est pas condamné lorsqu'elle se
conclut par un accouchement sous x c'est
la concomitance des deux qui trace la
ligne rouge dont je prédit qu'un jour
nous aurons à débattre car rien ne sera
figé dans le marbre
et heureusement que notre génération ne
condamne pas l'humanité pour l'éternité
par manque d'humanité humilité les
mentalités évoluent comme les techniques
et c'est toute la richesse de cette
démarche bio éthique que d'être
questionné régulièrement pour s'enrichir
de l'évolution des consciences pour cela
nous ne devons pas être privé de débats
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à laurence cohen pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous voici
enfin arrivée en nouvelle et dernière
lecture du projet de loi de bioéthique
près de deux ans après le début de cet
examen si évidemment le temps du débat
parlementaire et le rôle de chacune de
nos deux chambres est essentielle il
faut admettre que pour ce texte ce fut
un véritable parcours du combattant
un parcours du combattant plus simple
cela dit que celui mené par des milliers
de couples de femmes de femmes sol qui
attendent depuis plus de dix ans que les
promesses présidentielles d'ouverture de
la pma à tout se concrétise et malgré
les promesses je regrette monsieur le
ministre que le gouvernement ait retardé
l'inscription du projet de loi
bioéthique à l'ordre du jour
parlementaire
ainsi il est peu probable que le premier
bébé né par pma d'un couple de femmes ou
d'une femme seule naîtra avant la fin du
mandat d' emmanuel macron je veux dire
ici que j'éprouve une certaine colère
lorsque je repense à l'imbroglio du vote
du sénat en deuxième lecture ou la
majorité de droite a supprimé le droit à
la procréation médicalement assistée
pour tous les couples de femmes et les
mères célibataires
après avoir accepté l'ouverture de la
pma aux couples lesbiens mais limité son
remboursement par la sécurité sociale en
première lecture la droite sénatoriale
s'est radicalisée et caricaturée en
deuxième lecture en rejetant
complètement l'accès à la pma des
couples homosexuels mais aussi aux
femmes seules par une manoeuvre disons
le politicienne ce durcissement de la
position de la droite sénatoriale a
renvoyé une image de notre haute
assemblée en complet décalage avec le
reste de la société puisque 67% de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens soutiennent
l'élargissement de la pma aux couples de
lesbiennes et aux femmes seules
mais le gouvernement est lui aussi en
décalage avec la société
en refusant dans ce texte d'établir dès
la naissance de l'enfant d'un couple de
femmes
une filiation clair et solide en faveur
des deux femmes des deux parents
monsieur le ministre vous avez préféré à
une prose présomption automatique de
parenté une procédure spécifique pour
les couples de femmes qui devront passer
par une reconnaissance anticipée de
l'enfant devant notaire et l'ajout d'une
mention sur l'acte de naissance de
l'enfant
le maintien de deux régimes juridiques
distincts pour le mode d'établissement
de la filiation entre les couples
hétérosexuels hétérosexuels et les
couples de femmes créé une
discrimination selon l'orientation
sexuelle que je tenais à dénoncer je
regrette également que la technique dead
médicale dit ropa est été refusé par la
majorité gouvernementale aux couples
lesbiens
cette méthode de fécondation in vitro
est pourtant une solution pour des
couples de femmes qui décident d'avoir
un bébé ensemble et veulent tout de
participer activement à la grossesse
enfin il est dommageable de devoir
attendre encore pour autoriser les
personnes transgenres à accéder à la
procréation médicale assistée et à
l'auto conservation des gamètes
il nous semble donc pour toutes ces
raisons qu'un douvres nouvel échange
dans notre haute assemblée était
indispensable même si notre groupe est
favorable aux rédactions proposée par le
sénat sur la recherche sur les embryons
sur les cellules cellules souches
pluripotentes ou encore sur la
modification du génome qui nous
paraissent plus protectrice contre le
franchissement de la barrière des
espèces
nous voterons contre la motion de la
droite tendant à la question préalable
de la commission car nous savons qu'elle
est essentiellement lié à l'opposition à
la paix m
à deux jours de la marche des fiertés je
veux dire aux couples de femmes souvent
déçu et impatiente que cette fois ci ça
y est la loi va être malgré tout enfin
et définitivement adoptée
l'assemblée nationale ayant le dernier
mot et pour une fois je ne le regrette
pas un trait tant d'hésitations de
renoncement la pma pour tout sera
autorisée en france le camp des
progressistes a gagné contre celui des
rétrogrades
ils craignent que la société ne
s'effondre faute de figure paternelle
mais il reste beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir notamment pour mettre un terme
aux discriminations et aux violences
dont sont victimes les personnes lgbt y
plus je continuerai d'être à leurs côtés
et si malheureusement le vote du sénat
ne nous engueule en orgueil ipa je serai
ton ému de voir cette loi promulguée
pour reconnaître à toutes et tous le
même droit je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole et à
élisabeth doineau pour le groupe union
centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission mesdames messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
rares sont les projets de loi pour
lesquelles le parlement a encore
l'occasion de légiférer en procédure
normale
cet examen était donc une chance pour
nous de pouvoir prendre le temps
d'examiner avec sérénité ce projet de
loi bioéthique dont la nature même
impose le temps de la réflexion voire le
réexamen de ses propres positions et ce
fut le cas d'ailleurs je tiens à
remercier nos rapporteur qui n'ont pas
manqué tout au long de la navette
d'apporter l'éclairage et les précisions
nécessaires à la bonne tenue de nos
débats
malgré ce travail approfondi et leurs
efforts sans faille
force est de constater que la commission
mixte paritaire n'a pas pu trouver
d'accord et nous le regrettons amèrement
dans ce projet de loi mérite est de
trouver une voie médiane une voie
consensuelle une voie pragmatique
cette déception rassemble l'ensemble des
sénateurs tentaient leurs attentes elles
restent vrais y compris pour ceux qui
estiment que le volet sociétal de ce
texte n'y avait pas sa place en effet
même si nous n'avions pas eu à examiner
les premiers articles relatifs à la mp
les articles restant en discussion
montre que le consensus n'aurait quand
même pas pu être trouvée puisque au delà
des divergences profondes sur les
évolutions concernant l'assistance
médicale à la procréation
il n'en demeure pas moins vrai que
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
étaient face à des divergences
irréconciliables
en matière de recherche par exemple
beaucoup de choses ont été dites durant
cette navette
les articles ont été largement commentés
et je ne rappellerai pas aujourd'hui ce
qui a déjà été longuement débattue
quelques mots toutefois sur les
divergences irréconciliables
je pense aux articles 8 9 et 10 relatif
aux conditions de réalisation des
examens génétiques et de communication
de leurs résultats à l'intéressé et à sa
parentèle mais aussi aux articles 14 et
15 ou encore à l'article 17
n'interdisant la création d'embryons
chimérique que lorsqu'il résulte de la
modification d'un embryon humain par
adjonction de cellules provenant
d'autres espèces toutefois d'autres
articles ont fait l'objet de
rapprochements entre les deux chambres
notons ainsi que l'assemblée a conservé
partiellement l'un des apports du sénat
à l'article 16 bis qui ouvre le don du
sang aux majeurs faisant l'objet d'une
mesure de protection juridique avec
représentation relative au bien et
assistance à l'article cette terre
l'assemblée a approuvé la position du
sénat relative à l'encadrement du don du
corps
l'article 19 quater introduit par le
sénat a été validé par l'assemblée
nationale et concerne la réalisation en
première intention d'un examen génétique
chez les nouveau-nés dans le cadre du
dépistage néonatal pour la recherche
d'anomalies génétiques cible est
susceptible de mesures de prévention ou
de soins les députés ont également suivi
le sénat l'article 19 sur le diagnostic
prénatal et à l'article 23 sur la
revalorisation du rôle des conseillers
en gêner petit
malheureusement ces points d'accord ne
pèse pas lourd et qui plus est ce projet
de loi n'a pas permis de simplifier et
de clarifier la gouvernance de la
bioéthique
en effet les députés ont réintroduit à
l'article 29 6 membres supplémentaires
au sein du ccn
ils ont également confié des missions à
l' agence de biomédecine qui s'éloigne
de son coeur de métier enfin quelques
mots sur les premiers articles du projet
de loi relatif à l'assistance médicale à
la procréation dans la question de la
place de ces articles de ce projet de
loi que l'évolution qu'il propose on
divisait notre hémicycle y compris au
sein même de nos différents groupes
nous ne pouvions pas ignorer en
repoussant ou en modifiant
substantiellement les propositions qui
nous étaient faites que l'aboutissement
de la navette ne soldent se solderait
par l'adoption des articles en question
sans que l'assemblée ne prenne en compte
au moins partiellement la voie de notre
haute assemblée comme souvent à l'issue
d'une cmp non conclusives et à l'instant
où nous nous apprêtons à adopter une
question préalable
nous nous interrogeons sur notre
capacité à faire entendre notre voix
tel est pourtant le cadre que nous
impose notre constitution
en l'espèce tout en étant renforcée par
le fait majoritaire
toutefois l'intelligibilité de nos
débats est garantie par leur publication
au journal officiel et 1,9 à défaut
d'avoir pu modifier profondément le
dispositif de ce texte comme certains
d'entre nous le souhaitait j'estime
qu'il convient désormais de voter en
faveur de la question préalable qui nous
sera présentée par la commission
spéciale plutôt que d'ouvrir une
nouvelle discussion dont on connaît déjà
l'issue et qui ne serait qu'une redite
de ce qui est déjà consultable
c'est pourquoi le groupe union centriste
votera en faveur de cette motion de
procédure
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à marie pierre de la gontrie
pour le groupe socialiste écologie et
république
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous voici
chacun l'a rappelé à cette troisième
lecture de ce projet de loi enfin on dit
chacun des intervenants ces textes ayant
débuté son examen en juillet 2019 il ya
près de deux ans et c'est peu dire que
le gouvernement a temporisé en ne
souhaitant pas inscrire plus rapidement
ce texte à l'ordre du jour et qu'au
final perm a remis à la rappeler dix ans
se sont déroulées depuis la dernière
révision de la loi bioéthique mais ces
deux ans ne nous ont pas permis de
dépasser nos désaccords même si certains
l'ont relevé quelques avancées ont été
constatées
une fois n'est pas coutume nous avons eu
le temps de débattre tout le temps
puisque exceptionnellement il n'y avait
pas de procédure accélérée
mais bien évidemment le le fait que ce
débat était si distendu dans le temps ne
nous a pas permis de travailler
correctement et au final nous ressentons
une véritable déception législatives
entre le choix du gouvernement de mai
les réformes de la pma et révision des
lois bioéthiques la majorité en marche à
l'assemblée qui à l'évidence ne
souhaitait pas le moindre dialogue et
nous l'avons constaté en commission
mixte paritaire et la droite sénatoriale
camper sur des positions radicalement
opposées et donc je les dis le choix
d'introduire la réforme de la pma dans
le texte vise y est totalement toutes
chances d'aboutir à un consensus
et c'est effectivement ce qui s'est
passé nous l'avions souligné dès la
première lecture pourtant ce texte était
est nécessaire il est attendu
il touchait dans le domaine de la
bioéthique à de vastes domaines
mais tout cela a été rendu impossible
évidemment la majorité du sénat s'est
engouffrée dans cette brèche
personne ne souhaite a plus le consensus
et nous l'avons constaté au fil du temps
de fêtes l'issue était joué d'avancé
chacun campant sur ses positions et au
fond le défaut de cette question
préalable aujourd'hui on est aussi un
symptôme pourtant nous avions eu une
lueur en première lecture le sénat avait
accepté l'ouverture de la pma son
principe tout en l'encadrant là
mythe en en refusant de remboursement
mais ce mouvement ouvert et progressiste
a vite été rattrapé puisqu'en deuxième
lecture nous avons assisté à un
imbroglio parlementaire invraisemblable
qui s est traduit en tout cas par un
recul par le vote de l'amendement
excluant les femmes seules de la pma
mais aussi la suppression totale de
l'article 1er donc le sénat est passer à
côté de l'histoire en s'enfermant dans
une vision conservatrice de la famille
alors même et certains l'ont dit si
cette réforme ne détruira pas à la
famille nous le savons notre société
évolue les schémas familiaux aussi et
les schémas parentaux tout autant et
donc aujourd'hui le choix qui a été fait
et qui était possible c'était de faire
face à la réalité de notre société si
évidemment le choix que fait notre
groupe depuis fort longtemps
ces familles existent déjà elles sont
tout aussi heureuse que les autres
parfois plus car c'est l'enfant désiré
qui qui arrivent dans ces familles mais
souhaite simplement qu'on reconnaisse le
droit d'exister et de mettre fin à
l'hypocrisie d'encadrer des pratiques
pour garantir aux femmes la sécurité et
l'égalité
nous le savons notre histoire
parlementaire fourmille d'exemples de
textes qui ont servi de point de bascule
dans notre organisation sociale
nous avons souvent dans cet hémicycle
fait référence à la loi veil en 1973
nous pouvons aussi faire référence à la
loi ouvrant le mariage aux couples de
même sexe en 2013 et donc nous avons
l'occasion ici de constituer une avancée
sociétale du même ordre tout en veillant
évidemment à l'effectivité de ces droits
nouveaux sans discrimination bien sûr
notre groupe aurait souhaité aller plus
loin sur l'application du droit commun
sur la filiation pour les couples de
femmes sur les possibilités
d'autoconservation d'utilisation des
gamètes
ce sujet a été occultée évidemment les
questions de bioéthique sont
extraordinairement complexes
elles sont également politiques nous
devons en débattre collectivement mais
en réduisant les tensions entre la
science qui rend possible les
aspirations de la société
évidemment c'est l'objet de ces lois et
c'est à nous législateurs qu'il revient
de trouver l'équilibré le plus fin et le
plus jeune
c'est rappelons que la france dispose
d'un modèle spécifique en cette matière
puisque la législation sur la bioéthique
doit faire l'objet d'un réexamen
régulier
ce projet de loi consacre consacre ainsi
quand même plusieurs avancées la levée
en matière de dons d'organes de
certaines contraintes sur le
développement du don croisé
l'affirmation d'un statut de donneurs
d'organes
certaines clarifications sur
l'encadrement de la mg ou la création
d'une délégation parlementaire de
bioéthique nous aurions évidemment aimé
aller plus loin sur la question des dons
d'organes je l'avais déjà évoqué sur la
question des tests génétiques
car nous le savons tout cela est
souhaité par nos concitoyens ou
également ça a été rappelé par le
rapporteur tout à l'heure sur le
diagnostic pré embryonnaires évidemment
c'est donc un grand regret que je
souhaite manifester au nom de notre
groupe nous avons entendu l'annnonce de
cette question préalable sur lequel nous
allons remonter à lyon de revenir dans
quelques instants pour tout dire si
cette motion préalable devait être
rejetée nous pourrions quasiment pour
notre groupe
voté le texte qui a émané de l'assemblée
malgré quelques divergences car nous
considérons que l'humanité doit pouvoir
faire des progrès sans bouleverser nos
valeurs identifier des risques instituer
des garde-fous faire avancer les droits
de chacun en particulier ceux des femmes
et cela pour nous le rôle du législateur
c'est notre état d'esprit et les très
regrettable que le sénat ne l'est pas
partagé bien merci chers collègues la
parole maintenant à catherine de roche
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
la salle cool monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je tiens tout d'abord à saluer le
travail de nos collègues rapporteur
muriel jourda corinne imbert olivier
henno bernard jomier sans oublier bien
sûr le président la commission spéciale
un ami longue qui animait nos débats
lors de l'examen des lois de bioéthique
la question qui se pose à nous toucher l
intime et on la matière nul ne détient
la vérité chacun doit pouvoir exprimer
son opinion
la bonne tenue de nos débats au cours
des deux précédentes lecture est à
souligner il est en effet essentiel
d'écouter et de respecter chaque opinion
même si j'ai entendu des propos un peu
excessif ce matin c'est l'honneur de
notre assemblée d'avoir permis un débat
ouvert sur un sujet aussi complexe au
sein de notre groupe la liberté sur ce
sujet restait totale tout au long des
débats
chacun a pu se prononcer selon ses
convictions ses croyances son histoire
et ses doutes
la nouvelle lecture du projet de loi
bioéthique conséquence de l'échelle de
la commission mixte paritaire nous
laisse un goût amer un accord sur la
révision difficile à trouver dès lors
que le gouvernement avait fait le choix
d'y inclure les modifications sociétale
de l'accès à l'assistance médicale à la
procréation
si cette question a fait l'objet d'un
texte distinct nous aurions peut-être pu
aboutir un texte commun entre nos deux
assemblées comme ce fut le cas lors des
précédentes révisions de 2004 et 2011
la pma pour tout et bientôt la gpa
le principe de l'article 1er pause
opposé au nom d'une égalité en matière
de droit à l'enfant et à la
programmation devrait intellectuellement
inclure la gestation pour autrui au
cours de l'article 1er en deuxième
lecture devant le sénat
monsieur le secrétaire d'état de rien
taquet affirmé que l'ouverture de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
sera sans incidence sur l'interdiction
de la gestation pour autrui qui est
antinomique des grands principes
bioéthiques
auquel nous sommes tous attachés
aujourd'hui sans doute mais demain on
nous expliquera avec la même assurance
qu'il s'agit d'une réforme de justice
entre les couples de femmes et d'hommes
ce qui sera en table et on nous vendre
alors une super a dit éthiques
toutes les propositions de la commission
spéciale en matière de progression de
sudation été écartée par les députés
tout en actant l'ouverture de la mp aux
couples de femmes aux femmes non mariées
elles avaient maintenu le critère
médical notamment d'infertilité d'accès
à la mp pour les couples hétérosexuels
et réserver la prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale aux démarche fondée sur
des motifs médicaux la confusion sur le
vote de l'amendement instaurant la mp
post mortem a entraîné lors de la
seconde délibération l'article 1er le
rejet de cet article en deuxième lecture
promouvoir une égalité totale entre les
couples est illusoire un enfant aura
toujours deux lignées parentales
différentes
c'est ce qui est inscrit dans genre
humain universellement mixte
on ne peut dire un enfant qu'il est né
de père ou de mère
même s'il peut en effet être élevée dans
une famille mono ou homoparentales
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a motivé la
rédaction de l'article 4 sur la
filiation adoptées par notre assemblée
en première et deuxième lecture
nous avions refusé le principe d'une
filiation établie sur le fondement de la
volonté pure pour les deux maires et
nous avions considéré l'adoption comme
l'unique possibilité d'établir une telle
filiation
le sénat a également souhaité un
contrôle plus strict de la
reconnaissance de la filiation d'un
enfant né à l'étranger à l'issue d'une
gp et avait introduit l'article 4 bis
qui interdit tout transcription complète
à l'état civil dans les quatre gp à la
transcription du lien biologique de
filiation établie mais l'autre
transcription se fait par d'autres
moyens qu'une transmission automatique
c'est à dire l'adoption conservant la
levée de l'anonymat
en matière de dons des gamètes j'ai été
favorable à titre personnel chacun de
savoir qui il est et d'où il vient
la quête de leurs origines pour les
enfants nés sous x ou par amp un
véritable combat certes le donneur n'est
pas le parent mais faire don de ces
gamins tu n'as pas un acte anodin et
banale car c'est transmettre une part de
sa propre identité
aures les pays ayant levé l'anonymat ont
vu non pas une diminution du nombre des
donneurs mais un changement du profil de
ceux ci en ce qui concerne le don
d'organes de tissus et si lille et
cellule est regrettable que la position
du sénat sur le statut d'honneur ainsi
que sur l'abaissement de l'âge du
consentement pour le prélèvement de
cellules hématopoïétiques et sur les
dispositions relatives aux majeurs
protégés n'ait pas été retenue par les
députés les questions bioéthiques
fondamentales comme celles liées à la
recherche ont été occultés par les
débats sur la procréation et
d'affiliation sur le volet relatif à la
recherche le sénat s'attacher à
concilier ce que la science peut
apporter en termes de connaissance de
diagnostic précoce de dépistage et donc
de traitement suscitant des espoirs
considérable et le refus de pratiquer
parfois déjà en vigueur dans d'autres
pays moins disant sûr pratique la
médecine génomique doit être soutenu
dans son uniforme dans un cadre sécurisé
le sénat avait trouvé le juste équilibre
éviter un risque génique l'assemblée
nationale a persisté à vouloir autoriser
la création d'embryons chimérique par
l'adjonction de cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines
un embryon animal à défaut d'un
encadrement crédible le sénat s'était
positionné contre cette possibilité lors
des deux premières lectures de même sur
la modification du génome d'un embryon
mêmes signes de l'obstination de
l'assemblée nationale à vouloir
maintenir des dispositions sans valeur
ajoutée les députés ont réintroduit lé 6
membres supplémentaires issus du secteur
associatif au sein du csn nous allons
nous prononcer dans quelques instants
sur la motion présentée par la
commission spéciale leur établissement
par l'assemblée nationale la quasi
totalité de son texte y compris sur des
points pourtant
non clivant démontre sa détermination
une fois de plus à ne pas tenir compte
des propositions du sénat pour toutes
ces raisons une large majorité du groupe
l'est républicain
votre a en faveur de la question
préalable bien merci chers collègues
nous en avons terminé avec la discussion
générale qui est donc close nous passons
la discussion la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable
mesdames muriel jardin corinne imbert et
monsieur olivier henno non la commission
spéciale ont déposé une motion
distribuée sur le sous le numéro un
tendant à opposer la question préalable
au texte sans discussion je vais donc
passer la parole à un orateur pour est
un orateur contre madame muriel jourda
pour la motion pour dix minutes
ce président monsieur le ministre du
président de la commission spéciale mes
chers collègues il m'appartient donc de
présenter la motion tendance à opposer
la question préalable sur cette
troisième lecture de la loi de révision
bioéthique
vous savez lorsque nous aurons adopter
si nous l'adoptons cette motion nous
arrêtons là la discussion de ce texte
qui retournera tel qu'il nous est arrivé
à l'assemblée nationale ce texte n'a pas
été adopté en commission à l'unanimité
mais il a une majorité assez importante
parce qu'on l'a compris lorsque nous
avons entendu les précédents orateurs
cette motion ne signifie pas une
hostilité de la commission ou même du
sénat à l'ensemble des dispositions que
contient ce projet de loi bioéthique
il ya même un certain nombre de
dispositions sur lesquelles nous avions
pu trouver à un accord entre nos deux
assemblées
mais ce texte signifie cette motion
signifie que sans doute nous sommes
arrivés au bout de ce que doit être une
discussion parlementaire
la discussion ne vaut pas pour elle même
elle ne vaut que pour les changes
qu'elle introduit entre les deux
assemblées
elle ne vaut que parce qu'elle est un
processus de coûts
instruction de la loi de réflexion de
maturation d'examen des arguments qui
sont avancés par les uns et les autres
parlementaires de façon à ce que nous
essayons de trouver un accord sur ce
texte
or force est de constater que cette
discussion a assez vite pris fin
pourquoi j'y vois deux causes majeures
qui ont l'une et l'autre était évoquée
d'ailleurs par les différents orateurs
devant cette assemblée la première cause
elle est liée au fait que ce texte
entretient tout de même un mélange des
genres est une assez grande confusion
sur des dispositions qui relèvent de la
bioéthique tels que la recherche sur
l'embryon et sur des dispositions qui
sont selon l'expression consacrée
sociétale et évidemment nous pensons
tous aux dispositions relatives à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
et notamment à son extension aux couples
de femmes et aux femmes seules et sur
ces sujets outre le fait que la première
partie sociétal a complètement phagocyté
le débat qu'il soit dans les médias
d'ailleurs mais qu'il soit également
dans dans les assemblées sur ces sujets
il était parfois difficile pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous d'avoir une
position favorable sur l'intégralité de
ces deux dispositions de sorte que le
débat tom thum été très largement
parasitée par ce mélange des genres qui
avait été introduit dans le projet du
gouvernement
la deuxième raison je crois qu'elle
s'est très clairement résumé lorsque
nous nous sommes rendus à la commission
mixte paritaire où la position qui nous
a été exposé par nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale pourrait se
résumer en cette phrase politique
extrêmement connue vous avez
juridiquement tort parce que vous êtes
politiquement minoritaire
autrement dit nous sommes minoritaires
donc l'assemblée nationale fait ce
qu'elle veut loin de moi de nier
l'existence du fait majoritaire qui
évidemment intimement liés à la
démocratie mais ça a été dit aussi nous
ne parlons pas d'un texte comme un autre
aujourd'hui nous parlons d'une oie de
société qu'il s'agit des dispositions
biotique ou des dispositions que
sociétal les lois de sociétés n'ont pas
vocation à bouleverser notre société
elles n'ont pas vocation à faire état
d'une opinion d'une majorité
parlementaire elles ont vocation à
constater un état de la société et à le
traduire dans la législation
or un état de la société est rarement
homogène et sur les sujets qui étaient
abordés nous n'avons pas dans la société
d'homogénéité
les états généraux de la bioéthique si
vous avez bien voulu je suis penché loue
tout à fait révélé qu'il s'agisse des
sujets bioéthique eux mêmes mais
également des sujets sociétaux et il
était important que pour ce type de
texte
nous recherchions consensus je rappelle
que toutes les lois bioéthique se sont
votés par consensus jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est la première fois qu'un texte va
être votée sur l'opinion unique de
l'assemblée nationale et non pas sur un
dialogue constructif entre les deux
assemblées
il faut le souligner je crois c'est
extrêmement important
nous n'avons pas pu avoir ce dialogue
parce que nous avions juridiquement tort
puisque nous étions politiquement
minoritaire
cela est bien dommage et je crois qu'il
faut véritablement le déplorer comme un
certain nombre d'intervenants l'ont fait
voilà me semble-t-il les deux causes
majeures qui font que aujourd'hui nous
ne pouvons constater que la discussion
ne pourriez avoir ne serait qu'une
sussex une succession de monologues et
non plus le dialogue que nous aurions dû
avoir entre nos deux assemblées
et puis mais c'est peut-être un propos
plus personnel je crois que dans le fond
nous n'avons peut-être pas la même
conception des choses entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat sur ce texte
bioéthique
j'en veux pour preuve le la discussion
autour de l'article 7 alors l'article 7
tels que je voulais non ce un signe ne
n'évoque peut-être pas grand-chose pour
mais vous vous rappellerez peut-être les
débats que nous avons eus en séance
l'article 7 est relatif au don d'organes
vous savez que le don d'organes post
mortem après notre mort nous sommes tous
présumés y avoir consenti il ya une
présomption de consentement au don
d'organes post mortem souffre aussi de
notre vivant nous souhaitons nous
inscrire sur un registre à cet effet le
sénat sur un amendement de bernard
jomier d'ailleurs notre collègue
rapporteur avait
exclu de ce consentement les personnes
majeures sous protection
les personnes majeures qui bénéficient
d'une protection la personne c'est à
dire qu'ils ne sont pas capables
d'exprimer un consentement et donc ils
ne seront pas capables de refuser ce don
post mortem
ça paraît assez naturel que les
personnes protégées soient protégés pour
respect de la personne pour respect de
leur dignité
cela a été supprimée à l'assemblée
nationale avec cet argument qui a été
soutenu d'ailleurs par monsieur le
ministre de la santé
cet argument qui consistait à dire mais
non nous devons traiter tout le monde de
la même façon car nous sommes en pénurie
de dons d'organes
donc nous devons utiliser tout ce qui
t'attend notre disposition et fisam ans
ces personnes majeures sous protection
nous finissons par les considérer comme
des banques d'organes bien voyez-vous au
delà des deux causes majeures que
j'évoquais précédemment sur le fait que
cette discussion est terminée entre nous
je me demande si tout simplement nous
avons la même conception de la dignité
de la personne humaine
je vous remercie
bien la parole est maintenant à xavier
iacovelli contre la motion pour dix
minutes également
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous nous
devions aujourd'hui examiné en troisième
lecture le projet de loi relatif à la
bioéthique
je dis bien nous devions car la majorité
sénatoriale présente une motion dont on
a reposé la question préalable qui sera
vraisemblement vraisemblablement rejeter
et entraînera donc le rejet du texte
je regrette ce choix je le regrette tout
d'abord parce que ce texte porte en lui
des avancées nécessaires et importantes
je le regrette surtout car au delà des
désaccords qui nous oppose le sénat se
prive de débattre sur un texte important
qui intéresse les français au regard des
nombreux sujets de société qu'il traite
il a fait l'objet d'un large consensus
au même lors de son inscription à
l'ordre du jour avant même lors de
l'inscription de à l'ordre du jour les
états généraux de la bioéthique se sont
déroulés en premier semestre 2018 durant
lesquels les citoyens les associations
les courants de pensée philosophique ou
religieux les professionnels de santé et
les experts scientifiques ont participé
aux réflexions dans chaque territoire
des débats ont été organisés par des
espaces de réflexion éthique régionaux
sur neuf thématiques identifiées par le
ccn eux que nous retrouverons en grande
partie dans ce texte je le disais ce
projet de loi traite de sujets de
société majeur je pense à l'accès aux
origines de l'enfant né d'une aide
médicale à la procréation d'un tiers
donneur et la gestion des traitements de
données relatifs aux tiers donneur à
leurs dons et aux enfants nés de ces
dons je pense également à des sujets
complexes comme lotto conservation des
ovocytes et la recherche sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires
je pense bien sûr à l'ouverture de la
procréation médicalement assistée à
toutes les femmes et à la prise en
charge par l'assurance-maladie avancées
sociétales majeures qui figurait
d'ailleurs dans le projet présidentiel
du président macron sur ce dernier point
pourtant centrale comment expliquer les
volte face de la majorité sénatoriale
entre la première lecture vous aviez
adopté les dispositions relatives à la
pma
certes en limitant le jouant son
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
aux seuls cas d'infertilité et la
seconde lecture
ou de manière incompréhensible vous
rejeter l'article 1 après avoir exclu
les femmes seules
pourquoi refuser de débattre à nouveau
et suite aux difficultés rencontrées
lors de la seconde lecture
j'aimerais d'ailleurs qu'on s'y attarde
la suppression de l'article 1 dès le
premier soir du débat suivi du rejet
également de l'article 2 un texte qui
après plusieurs heures d'examen n'était
que l'article 1a prévoyant qu'il
n'existait pas de droit à l'enfant
ensuite une nouvelle délibération
annoncé à plusieurs reprises mais jamais
réalisées et des contradictions
multiples alors bien sûr nous n'étions
nous étions satisfaits que l'amendement
de cohérence que nous portions assurer
l'accès au diagnostic préimplantatoire
pour les femmes non mariées à l'article
19 étaient adoptés en séance
mais comment expliquer que la même
assemblée rejeté quelques jours
auparavant la possibilité de réaliser d
aide médicale à la procréation pour ces
mêmes femmes vous dites dans une tribune
je parle de la majorité sénatoriale
vous dites dans une tribune publiée dans
le journal la croix je cite l'exécutif
fait preuve d'une absence catastrophique
du sens des priorités et des
responsabilités en réinscrivant ce texte
à l'ordre du jour vous appeliez
l'exécutif à la raison et ben moi je
vous invite au respect du débat
démocratique et de nos prérogatives
celui d' examiner de construire et de
voter la loi trop souvent vous parlez du
mépris du parlement
mais combien de motion tentant a opposé
la question préalable vous avez déposé
la deuxième lecture du plfss celle du
plf celle de la ppl visant à améliorer
le système de santé par la confiance et
la simplification
je ne parle même pas de la suppression
de l'article 1 de la proposition de loi
pour le droit à mourir dans la dignité
vidant ainsi sa substance ce texte tant
attendu par les français
l'émotion les unes après les autres
limite nos débats limite notre rôle
démocratique celle que vous présentez
aujourd'hui est motivée par le site
le fait que selon vous le dialogue entre
nos deux assemblées n'a jamais eu lieu
je me permettrai de ne pas aimer ni
énumérés à nouveau
les apports que vous avez mentionné dans
l'exposé des motifs de cette motion mais
je dois en citer quelques autres la
possibilité d'actualiser les données
médicales - identifiantes concernant le
couple où la femme ayant consenti à
l'accueil d'un embryon dans
l'établissement chargé de mettre en
oeuvre la procédure
le principe selon lequel un employeur ne
peut proposer en charge la prise en
charge des frais d'autoconservation la
possibilité de préciser les conditions
de conservation des gamètes en cas de
décès le fait que l'absence de
révocation par écrit du consentement par
les délais impartis vos confirmation et
enfin la consultation de la cnil par et
la durée minimum de conservation des
données relatives aux tiers donneur et
ses quelques apports ne proviennent que
des trois premiers articles du projet de
loi
il ne s'agit pas évidemment d'être
d'accord sur tout chers collègues les
désaccords sont légitimes c'est
d'ailleurs le propre de notre démocratie
dans les sujets sociétaux et de
bioéthique sont complexes touche à nos
consciences individuelles et découle de
la conception même de ce que la société
française et de son évolution
ces divergences d'opinion traverse les
groupes politiques au delà des clivages
il touche à l'intimé parfois même à
notre histoire personnelle
le débat renforce les décisions
collectives et c'est par la
confrontation des visions que nos
sociétés évoluent ses points de vue
divers sont présents au sein même de
notre groupe et nous les appuyons avec
bienveillance laissant chacun libre de
son vote et de son positionnement mais
unie derrière la recherche du dialogue
alors faisons honneur à la haute
assemblée
montrons aux français l'importance du
bicamérisme dans notre démocratie
soyons à la hauteur des enjeux les
questions abordées dans ce projet de loi
quelles que soient nos divergences sont
au coeur de la société et méritent
d'être débattus c'est pourquoi chers
collègues je vous appelle à voter contre
cette motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable
le groupe air des pays en cohérence le
fera pour permettre au sénat de débattre
de débattre sur ce texte
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je vais donc
demander d'abord l'avis du gouvernement
sur cette motion et ensuite nous verrons
s'il ya des demandes d'explications de
vote
merci monsieur le prêt pardon merci
monsieur le président comme je
l'évoquais enfin de magret ration
général je regrette mais prend acte de
cette de cette motion tendant à l'opposé
la question préalable pour lequel le
gouvernement émet donc un avis
défavorable
yat il ya t'il maintenant des
explications de vote
monsieur juillet ensuite il merci
monsieur le président sur le fond du
texte qui nous est transmis par
l'assemblée nationale
marie pierre de la gontrie l'a dit s'il
était soumis à un autre vote malgré les
imperfections qui contient nouveau
torrio nous et mettrions un vote
favorable nous nous rejetterons pas
cette question préalable parce que nous
on constat qu'après deux lectures et une
cmp qui a échoué
il ne sert à rien de prolonger le débat
et ne sert à rien de s'appuyer sur le
fait que sur tant d'autres textes
le gouvernement utilise la procédure
accélérée pour dire que cette fois ci il
faut prolonger au delà de ce qui est
raisonnable j'appelle plutôt mes
collègues qui soutiennent la majorité
présidentielle et le gouvernement sur
les eaux texte a cessé cette procédure
accélérée permanente car sur ce texte
les deux lectures dans le parlement le
ministre l'a rappelé ont permis des
avancées et des progrès c'est donc utile
c'est donc utile surtout les textes mais
pour autant nous ne voterons pas la
question préalable au fond parce que on
ne peut pas chérir des effets dont on
déplore les causes et si nous en sommes
arrivés là et que il est tout à fait
piteux que l'examen de la loi de
bioéthique je suis d'accord avec muriel
jourda se termine de cette façon en
queue de poisson
ce n'est pas comme ça que doit se
terminer une loi de bioéthique elle doit
se terminer dans le consensus le plus
large possible mais les causes elles
sont à rechercher du côté du
gouvernement qui en mêlant à la révision
des lois de bioéthique
une autre problématique à créer les
conditions de l'échec de l'examen il
faudrait que la procédure de révision la
loi de bioéthique sur la définition du
contenu soit extraite de contingences
qui sont plus politiciennes qu'autre
chose et qu'on cesse de donner à
l'exécutif tout pouvoir pour déterminer
quel est le cadre de la révision des
lois de bioéthique mais c'est aussi la
responsabilité de la majorité
sénatoriale qui s'est mis hors-jeu qui a
mis hors jeu
notre chambre lors de la seconde lecture
et il n'y a pas que des membres de
l'opposition sénat pour le dire faut-il
vous le rappeler est donc cet échec vous
en sortez par cette motion de procédure
eh bien vous en assumer la
responsabilité
pour notre part nous avons été constants
sur ce texte oui aux droits des femmes
oui aux progrès de la recherche
scientifique et non à cette confusion
merci cher collègue monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
n'avons pas été surpris par le dépôt de
cette motion
tant les divergences sont grands tendre
l'assemblée nationale et la majorité
sénatoriale
c'était un peu évident que nunavut
dirions pas par contre nous avons
vainement regretter ce qui s'est passé
au cours de la seconde lecture où le
débat était complètement tronqué ou la
majorité sénatoriale a durci son
positionnement supprimant l'article 1
en plus on peut dire que la parole
donnée n'a pas été respecté puisqu'il y
avait eu un engagement de revenir sur
l'examen de cette cet article 1
donc effectivement nous avons une
certaine déception une rancoeur face à
ce débat qui ne s'est pas tenue comme il
aurait dû
se tenir et nous aurions pu voter contre
cette motion toutefois nous savons que
cette loi est très attendu que des
associations nous ont fait part de cette
volonté que cette loi entre en vigueur
au plus vite donc c'est pour cette
raison que le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire s'abstiendra sur
cette motion
merci monsieur chasse un monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
membre de la commission mais chaque
collègue
moi je suis en ce qui me concerne
favorable à la pma et je vais voter la
question près là pourquoi parce que j'ai
confiance aux rapporteurs qui ont fait
un très très gros travail et il n'aurait
donc expliqué ne pas avoir été écoutés
et surtout ne pas avoir été entendu et
moi je n'ai aucune raison de ne pas leur
faire confiance le scénar ans a été dix
deuxième lecture
il ya eu un vote contre l'article 1 mais
le sénat avait voté favorablement
l'article en première lecture
alors effectivement il y avait beaucoup
de gens en contre mais la majorité
s'étaient prononcés pour
donc c'était ça qui était primordial et
à partir de là je pense que on pouvait
avoir une entente dans le cadre du
bicamérisme avec l'assemblée nationale
parce que on pouvait avoir mon avis un
article 1 à une entente sur la position
prise par le sénat sur l'article 4 sur
l'adoption sur l'anonymat des donneurs
je pense qu'il pouvait y avoir aussi
d'entendre la gpa je pense que
là ce qui est ce qui a été l'article 4 2
qui a été mis en place à ce niveau là me
paraissait tout à fait adapté et au
niveau du don d'organes également je
pense que pour tout ces ces dispositions
bien sûr qu'ils sont pas secondaire mais
à partir du moment où on avait voté
favorablement pour les pma et bien je
regrette qu'ils aient pas eu une avancée
une d'ouverture de l'assemblée nationale
merci bien je dis oui alesi chacune
merci monsieur le président on ne se
munissent mes chers collègues je vais
bien entendu voter cette motion tendant
à opposer la question préalable d'abord
pour les raisons qui ont été indiquées
par muriel jourda mais également parce
que je crois vraiment qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de discuter de ce si aujourd'hui je
le dis comme je le pense
est-ce qu effectivement il y avait une
urgence dans le cadre une absence totale
de consensus entre les deux chambres de
voter une loi certes qualifiée de
bioéthique mais qui aurait les
répercussions sociétal que l'on connaît
dont on a parlé est ce qu'il y avait
urgence
au moment où on est en train
difficilement de sortir d'une pandémie
avec les difficultés économiques et
sociales que vous connaissez on va des
structures et en plus la société non il
n'y avait vraiment pas l'urgence urgence
à faire cela et il n'y avait donc pas
aujourd'hui lieu d'en discuter journée
si je crois que je n'ai plus
d'explications de vote des groupes donc
je vais passer la parole à alain milon
président de la commission spéciale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord revenir sur ce qui a été
dit par monsieur à covelli en ce qui
concerne la deuxième lecture
c'est vrai que dans le cas de la
deuxième lecture ce qui a été voté par
la majorité n'est pas ce qui a été voté
dans le cas de la première lecture mais
pour une raison simple c'est le duo
cafouillage au cafouillage d'un
président de séance qui n'a pas voulu
raconter l'ensemble des voix mais
il avait fait nous aurions changé le
vote donc le cafouillage vient d'un
président qui vient jeou devront en plus
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point en commission mixte paritaire uni
assistiez pas en commission mixte
paritaire la rapporteure de la
commission mixte paritaire de
l'assemblée nationale nous a fait
comprendre à nous à moi président et au
rapporteur du sénat que nous étions
minoritaires et que étaient majoritaires
et qu'en conséquence était la majorité
qui avait raison ça voulait dire aussi
quelques parcs juridiquement nous avions
quelques partants parce que nous étions
minoritaires
ça nous rappelle un discours de valence
et quelques années en arrière qui est
extrêmement désagréable
je tenais à vous le dire parce que c'est
important dans la discussion et en
particulier pour la population qui nous
écoutent aujourd'hui pour le reste ce
projet doit monsieur le ministre on
tient deux choses d'abord la partie bio
éthique et là je pense que les
rapporteurs avaient fait un travail
assez considérable nettement d'ailleurs
supérieur à celui de l'assemblée
nationale et les avancées qui avaient
été mises en place dans la première
lecture par le rapporteur était beaucoup
plus importante pour les doctorants et
pour les post doc que ce que quelques
amis pardon l'assemblée nationale dans
le texte je pense à g éthique je pense
aux cellules souches je pense à la
recherche sur l'embryon
nous étions en avance sur l'assemblée
nationale mais de votre texte a été
parasitée complètement parasité par la
pm par la pma pour les femmes seules
pour les femmes en couple vous savez que
j'y suis favorable et même que je suis
favorable à gpa donc je vais encore plus
loin que vous pour certains d'entre vous
toujours peut-être pas pour vous
directement mais pour certains d'entre
vous toujours
il est évident il est évident que la pme
ayant parasité le texte nous ne pouvions
pas là je rejoins ce qu'a dit notre
collègue rdse tout à l'heure mais ce
monsieur fiolet ne pouvions pas la
majorité voté un texte aussi global il
ya une partie pma c'était du sociétal je
leur ai voté sans problèmes
une partie bioéthique j'aurais voté le
texte de nora porter parce qu'il va
beaucoup plus loin pour nos chercheurs
que le texte de l'assemblée nationale en
conséquence et la suite de ce que j'ai
entendu
est ce que je vais vous dis je voterai
quand même la question préalable
bien merci monsieur le président donc de
je vais maintenant consulté le sénat sur
la motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable j'ai été saisi une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe les
républicains sur la question préalable
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est favorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
bien le scrutin est clos
à
donc voici le résultat du scrutin numéro
136 sur la motion un compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs ou groupes
politiques et notifiée à la présidence
nombre de votants 343 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 252 pour l'adoption
191 contre 61
la motion est donc adoptée en
conséquence le texte est considéré comme
rejetée
[Musique]